what up guys welcome to the J pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
another episode of pearl daily where I
cover this week's treachery debauchery
and craziness um so today I wanted to
talk about this phenomenon that I see in
society of just overweight models now as
you guys know the way that I view
modeling is that modeling is supposed to
be the epitome of beauty these are
supposed to be women that are eights
nines and tens and in the last couple of
years I have not seen the level of
beauty that I used to I mean when I was
a kid it was common to see women as
beautiful as Angelina Jolie Megan Fox
and even Jennifer Aniston in her youth
as the models in a lot of these movies
and shows but now what I've seen is more
average looking women being put in above
average results now recently I actually
saw a woman that I would deem as an ater
higher walking down the runway and I
thought to myself this is one of the
most beautiful women that I have seen in
a long time let's pull up the
video she is a
super she got to meet her and was so
excited she was literally shaking my
guess is that after tonight shanus is
going to have some super fans of her own
work it
[Applause]
AGA now I'd like to say first I have to
deem this inappropriate for a wife and a
mother
sorry guys sorry I do I do have to
preface this but it was actually so
encouraging to see a woman that was so
exceptionally beautiful this is one of
the most beautiful women that I have
seen in a long time and that's what the
women are supposed to look like they're
supposed to be in shape they're supposed
to have a very symmetrical face and they
are supposed to be an example of beauty
that we see in society notice she's
around 22 years old yes older women
should not be in these Beauty
competitions it is supposed supposed to
be a young woman's game but more and
more older bitter women that are mad
that they're not the ultimate epitome of
hotness and that their looks are fading
will continually try to shame men for
what they like they don't like fat women
they don't like old women and they like
young beautiful women and I quote
tweeted this I said this is one of the
most beautiful women that I have ever
seen I got a lot of responses saying
pearls engagement farming all this stuff
and really I wasn't even thinking about
I was just really Amazed by how
good-looking this chick was it has been
so long since I have seen a chick that
is that goodlooking really put in Beauty
competitions because even Victoria
Secret fashion shows um they they start
putting in trans people they start
putting in older women they start
putting in overweight women and I just
thought to myself this is what we are
meant to see I want to open a magazine
guys and I want to feel a little bit bad
about myself yes yes yes yes I want to
open the magazine and be like dang it I
don't have a body like that I don't look
like that but you know the same way a
basketball player can go to an NBA game
and say okay I'm not that good at
basketball but it gives you something to
Aspire to and Beauty should be
celebrated it should absolutely be
celebrated and it should not be a case
where we are telling average women that
they are more beautiful than they are it
is okay to be average aage the same way
it is okay to play basketball at your
local wck league and not be in the NBA
it is okay most people are average um
but when you start telling everybody
that they're so special and beautiful
and amazing and awesome that's when you
get overweight women asking 500k men
because they've never been told they're
an average chick it is okay to be
average you don't have to be the most
beautiful one in the room you can still
find a husband and get married it is not
the end of the world so then um I saw
another video going viral of an
overweight woman walking down the runway
let's pull it
[Applause]
[Music]
up okay so I had two thoughts my first
thought is this obviously is not the
most beautiful woman from that country I
think it's a Nepal guys let's not kid
ourselves that is not the most beautiful
woman that they have to offer she's
still good-looking I would say I would
say she's not I would say she still has
a good body shape but guys why are we
putting overweight women as the face of
the most beautiful women in these
countries I I don't shoot the messenger
but you're not going to put average
basketball players in the NBA just to
make them feel included but for whatever
reason women always want to feel like
they are included when sometimes it's
just meant for the best of the best then
my other question was do men still find
overweight women attractive and when I
saw the comments on this video most men
actually said they still found her
attractive men are not as picky as women
make them out to be most men are okay
with an even slightly overweight woman
but women will still say that men have
all of these high standards imagine the
only men that have super high standards
are the top 5 10 maybe 20% men most men
are not that picky so the comment
section weighs in on this Ian says the
internet is arguing whether this woman
is fat or not thought Lauren says this
woman is beautiful and has great
proportions but she is objectively fat
not morbidly obese but fat for sure
actually she might be morbidly OB she's
close she might be considered normal by
American Standards but only because most
Americans are fat yes Lauren is
absolutely right on this mistake Jay
says nothing wrong with boot delicious
the obsession with stick and toothpick
figures is unhealthy women have curves
it's how God made them and how men are
conditioned over the Millennia to be
attracted to so I am not even saying
that men should like stick than women I
mean the original woman that I showed
you guys she was still curvy she still
had curves she still you know I'm I'm
not going to go into it but it wasn't
like she was stick thin but women are
not meant to be overweight and I don't
know why we keep normalizing being
overweight it is not good we should not
have overweight women in beauty pageants
we should not have overweight women as
models I almost think that we should ban
fat clothes sometimes I think it would
be really motivating if we couldn't buy
clothes as women okay so the other thing
that I get in a lot of trouble for in
2023 is I I point out that women lose
their sexual value over time so this is
how I would say I would say most women
before the age of 25 relative ly look
young beautiful attractive as long as
they don't get fat now over the age of
25 this is where I see women typically
hit a mini wall they're starting to lose
their looks and I would say it depends
on the woman but between the ages of 25
and 35 their looks start to rapidly
decline some women can hold out to their
early 40s but really over the age of 45
your looks are practically gone and it's
not the end of the world women used to
know that one day they were going to
look like a Grandma but they get a good
husband who will love them and take care
of them for the rest of their life they
realized that they were more than their
sexual appeal they had to do other
things to be a good caring selfless wife
and that looks were not everything um so
there is a woman named Alicia
Silverstone and I wanted to point out
this trend now this is not to attack her
at all so Alicia Silverstone was one of
the most attractive women 20 30 years
ago and now she looks like an average
chick now all these women that say you
get better with age does she look better
than she did in the past and I'm going
to show you guys what she looks looked
like before if you don't know who she is
guys this isn't a bad thing you know a
lot of men don't age as well either but
there's different things that men and
women are attracted to and women are
attracted to money which goes up Social
Status which goes up where men don't
really care about those things so you
know the only exception I see of women
getting better with age is maybe if they
lose a bunch of wait but for some reason
women just cannot stand this I saw a
video I didn't actually watch the video
but I saw the title of of um Sydney
Watson's video saying you know shaming
men for going after barely legal women
well you know my question is is 20 years
old barely legal what is wrong with a 20
what is wrong with a 40-some year old
wanting to date a 20-year-old I I think
we need to stop shaming men for liking
what they like and live in reality and
just because you're getting older less
attractive more bitter it doesn't mean
we need to bend reality for you men like
what they like so the guy that tweeted
this is bad Billy Pratt it's kill to
party is his ass Alicia Silverstone was
the hottest girl on earth 30 years ago
don't lose your over a girl um and
how does the comment section take this
so they say she looks like her Dentures
are about to fall out men age like wine
women age like milk
and she actually took care of herself
most will look even worse yeah exactly
you know she doesn't even look terrible
for a woman of of that age but notice
how when someone when you say someone
looks good it's always you look good for
your age this was her back in the day
absolutely stunning and beautiful look
at that like literally stunning but
looks only last so long and that's why
they used to tell women to get married
and get married young then it won't
matter as much you don't have to be the
most beautiful woman in the room at some
point your looks will go okay so now
that I've um said that water is wet the
sky is blue older women are less
attractive okay so in the past couple of
years I have seen a trend of comedians
getting canceled for making jokes now
comedians are not supposed to be
politically correct they are supposed to
make fun of everybody and anybody but
for whatever reason certain groups think
that they are EXA to being made fun of I
have been made fun of women have been
made fun of men have been made fun of
all groups should be subject to being
made fun of because that is a comedian's
job to be funny and what they do is they
say uncomfortable true through comedy I
don't make the rules okay and I've seen
amazing and awesome comedians like for
example Dave Chappelle getting cancelled
for being funny um so there's a new
comedian named Matt R I've seen little
clips of him on Tik Tok here and there
he is a comedian faced criticism for a
domestic violence joke in his new
Netflix special natural selection in
response to the backlash he
sarcastically directed critics to a link
for a special needs helmet as an apology
this move further aggravated those upset
by his remarks R defended his comedy
stating his material was aimed at a more
male audience and that his intention was
solely to make people laugh however this
isn't the first instance of contr iers
surrounding R's content exactly do you
see this this is what women do women
always ruin everything now they're
trying to ruin comedy guys men you need
to push back on this and tell women to
get the F over it if you don't like the
comedy shows then get over it don't go
to them I am so tired of people thinking
that they are exempt from being made fun
of yes yes yes yes so another Trend that
I have seen in society is this trend of
women older women especially to write
music that really denigrates men and
they want to be a man I swear to Jesus
that a lot of these women want they they
think to themselves why wasn't I born a
man every day every day and I see this
because they make songs that sound like
something a guy would say um okay let me
let me let me show you this chick is
going viral on Tik Tok and I hate it
because her songs are actually a little
bit catchy like I kind of I kind of
bought my head slightly but you listen
to the lyrics and let's let's just pull
it up thank God I break up with my ex
cuz Mama didn't raise no she
didn't raise a woman just to take a
man's said I could have it all if I
really think big got to focus on the
back now the boys will be up on my dick
Mama didn't raise no dummy no falling
for a man who's to living with his money
I can my own bread I can make my own
money so I won be a nice pretty wife you
won't get a thing me okay wow I wanted
to I wanted to break down these lyrics
you know I used to do music reactions
back in the day I swear I you I used to
to break down l so I'm an expert at
Breaking Down lyrics She says thank God
I broke up with my ex cuz Mama didn't
raise no bit I didn't realize that the
standard for being like a strong Brave
woman was being able to break up with
somebody wow you know people used to go
to war I don't know do like incredibly
hard things but now you are officially
not a if you can dump somebody
okay all right she didn't raise a woman
just to take a man's okay so let me
I would say most women are in fact
raised to take men's because they
do that through child support alamon and
divorce or maybe she's saying I don't
want to take put up with your nonsense
but I mean does she really look like the
type that gives No Nonsense am I going
crazy
here said I could have it all if I
really think big okay so what what is
thinking big is thinking big putting out
a music video all right all right I got
to focus on the bag not the boys who be
up on my dick so this is what I mean do
you want to be a dude is that what
you okay Mama didn't raise no dummy she
says but okay but this is a
contradiction because that is
grammatically incorrect now guys as you
know anyone that follows me on Twitter I
can barely spell but she says Mama
didn't raise no dummy that's not it's
not grammatic all right you but you know
who maybe I'm just it's a song okay so
no falling for a man who's still living
with his mommy so my first question okay
is are is this a regular thing for you
is this like your do you enjoy like
because for me personally I'll tell you
I'll just I mean the first question
would be what like you know I have a
brother that lives with like at home but
it's not because he he's unsuccessful
it's just cuz he likes you know we're
we're tight-knit family you know but but
but if we're talking about the loser her
archetype which I think she is I'm I'm
getting some indication that you've done
this before I'm I'm getting some I'm
getting some inkling that maybe in the
past you've gone for guys that live with
their mom but okay let's just continue I
can bake my own bread wait from I
something tells me this chick um are you
telling me this chick makes her own
bread from
scratch what kind is it sourdough I like
sourdough now I'm not again I'm I'm not
a detective but something tells me this
woman is not baking bread that off I can
make my own money she says as she is
half naked now could you make your own
money covered up is my question I
because a lot of I have some inklings
that some of these chicks would not make
money if they had a turtleneck on that's
all I'm saying so I won't be your nice
pretty wife you won't get a thing from
me well at least she's being honest you
know any guy that dates this chick you
know she has been so honest that if you
get screwed in divorce later I don't
even feel bad for you because she
literally her l I won't be a pretty nice
wife so let's look at the comments
section and how they respond I tweeted
this CU I was like take her home to take
her home to dinner um Caleb says she
needs training any woman can be a great
mother but I doubt she would women need
to go back to what they're great at as
men do be a masculine man and she'll be
a feminine
woman I would not advise you to try with
this one but you know an unserious
person speaking to other unserious
people okay
she's not really all that attractive to
be doing these weird dance move and and
embarrassing herself like this yeah this
is a bit embarrassing but you know I
guess let them let them live but I will
give my comment yeah and I see this
trend on Tik Tok all these Tik Tock
girls come out and just it's almost like
they like to sing about their L's it's
almost like that because even this song
I'm reading these lyrics I'm thinking
like isn't it kind of an L to say you
won't be a
wife isn't it kind of kind of an L to
talk about not dating men who live with
their mom cuz it kind of indicates that
maybe at some point you know women used
to kind of be quiet about their L's like
you would kind of take your L and just
like move on you be oh dang it and and
you'd be quiet no one would know but
nowadays women want like an L put on
their forehead like it's like they just
want everybody to know about their L's
why would you who am I okay well all
right so our last story of the day um a
woman had a marriage of 12 12 years and
apparently she decided to ruin this
marriage for a really good and important
reason let's pull it up I am currently
dating slash in my phas um and my
longest relationship was probably my
marriage which was 12 years wait are you
divorced currently yes can you hold on
you're currently in your what phase
how long ago did you get divorced 3
years ago how long has your phase
been um 3 years
did did your phase start before or
after the divorce after I got divorced
it's actually been really healing like
after being super religious and super
conservative and censored and controlled
when you finally get out on your own and
ask yourself like what do I want what
brings me alive what makes me feel
connected and I found out it's not being
monogamous it's not being married it's
actually being open and available for
amazing connections with
[Music]
people yeah and this is why I had a I
had a coffee thought this morning okay
so sometimes you get the young woman who
is super religious and on paper is
everything you would ever want but if
she gets the wrong friends friend group
or starts watching the wrong media they
go down this crazy path and they they do
this free love hippie roughly the
these women tend to do at around 28 to
33 years old they'll marry their high
school sweetheart and then one day just
change and this is terrifying to men if
they can't get a better outcome with the
virgin chicks from the south what else
are they supposed to do I mean this
woman allegedly had was young she had
very little sexual experience but the
streets call the streets called her and
she left if she had children they are
the ones who will suffer the cost so the
comment section weighs in on this what
triggers me the most is that other women
are nodding with affirmation when that
lady is uttering some terrible
yeah yeah and that's when I say women
are not your friends they lead you down
the path of destruction this is the
problem we will make decisions that ruin
our entire lives and other women will
cheer us on and not tell us the truth
hulie says in a few years she's going to
be talking about how she can't find true
love and that men only want sex from her
yeah that's how men tend to view divorce
a most single mothers will not Remar I
want you guys to like beat this into
your head most single mothers do not
Remar they never get married most can't
even get a guy to live with them men Buy
and large do not want and do not marry
single mothers and I'm the bad guy for
pointing this out when it is true the
numbers will tell you it is
overwhelmingly true men are not lining
up to date single mothers Double J look
at the way the other girls look at her
like it is something to be proud of yes
okay so I wanted to Pivot slightly
Rachel Wilson is a good friend of the
show and her husband has a channel known
as The Crucible he this is a super super
smart guy he went on whatever podcast
and I just saw him destroy destroy these
women let me pull it
up back I just want just curious on
first W feminism is a grounding
Foundation why would you say that that
was good um I think because it
established us as human beings worthy of
having some rights like voting so you
think that voting rights were good
absolutely yeah but why how come women
didn't want them women don't want voting
how come they didn't want them um I
couldn't tell you yeah almost almost no
women wanted to vote and I wasn't aware
that they didn't want that I certainly
want voting rights why because I have an
opinion and I'm a human being yeah so
well let me ask you this women get the
right to vote because you want to expand
rights sure how come women when they
vote though usually vote for more
Security in the state rather than voting
to expand rights so it's been my
experience that usually nobody wants to
vote themselves a right to do a good
thing they always want to vote
themselves right for some form of
degeneracy I've never actually seen
someone say I want to be more free for
more responsibility I want to be more
free so that I have um more Duty in
society well then you haven't met me
because that's yeah so what would you so
do you want to vote for what do you want
the vote for exactly what do what do you
think should have vot what do you well
for me I'm a patriarch right so from
from the grounding from the grounding
Foundation you say you're a Christian
sure right okay okay so do you think in
society as a Christian in a Christian
Society why do you think that your
Founders didn't give women the right to
vote I never said anything about a
Christian Society yeah yeah but why do
you think the founders didn't give women
the right to vote I don't know and I
don't care you don't you don't care no I
don't probably because they were
probably because they were based in
religion right but I don't believe I
believe in separation of church church
and St you're standing more more like a
progressive and not a conservative to me
so if we move so we move into first wave
feminism so now you don't want you want
a separation between church and state as
well can you tell me other than like
some basic I don't like abortion what do
you actually disagree with Progressive
women on uh a lot of things like like I
believe that like what what do you mean
like feminism just give me anything
besides just I don't like abortion right
so what I I've noticed this trend of wom
are you trying to ask me if I
economically tell you I've noticed this
trend of women who are always like look
I'm a Trad girl right who patriarchy
based haha right I hear this all the
time the question though for me always
becomes this delineation when they're
like third and fourth wave feminism's
gone too far okay what about first wave
feminism oh well all the delineation
which led to third and fourth W feminism
I love all that just not what it turned
into to clarify I'm a Libertarian
leaning conservative Nick you can
unmute libertarian leaning so funny yeah
yeah hilarious what what are
Libertarians trying to conserve what do
you mean what are they trying to
conserve so you're a conservative
because you don't believe in what what
do you think conservative means
conservatism is rooted in preserving the
Traditions
that stop stop hold on for a second
conservatism is rooted in preserving the
traditions and ideals that this nation
was founded upon which were almost
entirely Christian and libertarianism is
often times not but there's also a
reason why they didn't kind
contradiction of terms no it's not
because you can still have those values
and not have them based 100% % saying
that it's because the Bible said this it
says nowhere in the Constitution because
the Bible said that well then what are
you making a foundation of well you can
still believe in those values no for
conservation you can still 100% I to to
be fair I am a Christian right I I
believe in Christianity but when it
comes to my political views I don't vote
based off of only my Christianity and I
also don't believe that we should
enforce those go ahead Savannah um so
basically what you're saying please is
um people that serve roughly 50% of the
population should have a say in let's
not linger too long on on this topic
please but
yes well because I seen a small question
after because the entirety of women's
voting inside of the United States has
been a complete unmitigated disaster
unmitigated disaster which has led us to
Progressive policies societal Decay a
society which cannot reproduce itself
literally can't even reproduce itself
it's led to every form of social
degeneracy you currently see inside of
society has been due 100% to women
voting let me give you the counter we as
women don't even know why we believe the
things we believe sometimes this chick
doesn't even know what conservatism is
Andrew was making such amazing points he
was making such awesome points yes women
getting the right to vote has led to
every form of degeneracy and really
again guys I believe in a natural order
of the world I believe it goes God men
women children just because you don't
think children shouldn't have certain
rights doesn't mean you hate children
just because you believe that women
shouldn't have certain rights it does
not mean you hate or dislike women women
and men are good at different things we
are meant to do different roles and I
don't think that is a bad thing Andrew
just destroyed destroyed that that woman
you guys you should subscribe to his
Channel It's called The Crucible he is
so funny and the other thing that he
pointed out is that half the time these
conservative women are are just it's so
interesting because they'll say they're
like Trad wives yet they always divert
the attention to themselves and not
their husband one way that I can point
out or think of if a woman is truly has
a more traditional mindset is does she
constantly point to herself and say yes
but I am married I do the chores I serve
my husband no because traditional women
do not need credit that is a modern
mentality give me credit I am so amazing
and awesome and special traditional
women play in the background and it's
actually interesting because Rachel um
I'm actually like good friends with
Rachel and you know one way I can kind
of see that she's the real deal is
literally this chick every opportunity
like I I talk to her about she's always
the first to to like bring her husband
up and like give him the credit and I
don't know it's just very like cute you
don't see that often anymore um okay but
enough about enough about that that is
the end of today's show um I'm going to
read the top comment from last show
which is I went to a singles senior
dance and there is nothing scarier than
seeing
70 no so last show guys I'm going to
give you some preface I talked about how
these chicks look like clowns they look
like clowns they have all this Botox on
their forehead um they they have all
these lip they just look silly they look
so silly and I'm not even against all
plastic surgery like I've seen some
girls look all right but some of these
chicks are just going they are overdoing
it and so this comment is in reference
to I I had this little stick where I was
talking about how these chicks look like
clowns I went to a single senior dance
and there's nothing scarier than seeing
70 plus year old women dressed like
they're 18 with a bucket load of makeup
on over a sea of melted
skin yeah it just looks silly like again
at some point guys we got to cover up
I'm not going to tell you exactly what
age that is I think your late 20s it's
time to start dressing a little more
modestly looking a little bit more
modest and not wearing these booty
shorts these crop tops you just you guys
just start to look silly you you look so
silly and you know it's one thing to
wear it for your husband but when you
guys are posting these selfies and it's
even more embarrassing oh gosh I see
these it's so embarrassing I see these
chicks that are are trying to do these
serious interviews wearing nothing I I
mean like this is just
getting and okay in your early 20s you
can get away with it but once you guys
start getting to your
30s oh my gosh it is so embarrass oh my
gosh there's I'm not going to say the
name it's so embarrassing this one
chick she's like 30 something all right
and this chick's like in like a booty a
booty outfit conducting a serious
interview I'm like
lady put it away why is it so hard for
us chicks to put it away it's so
embarrassing but let me know what you
guys think in the comments make sure you
like the video on your way out and
please please please leave a comment I
want to get to 500 comments on this
episode I will talk to you guys next
time thank you guys for watching if you
want to see more exclusive content with
no ads make sure you sign up for our
email list the link is in the
description